this is really the fighter and the kid
come on baby
now here's the thing maybe I'm I'm put
in jail what's the first thing you do
the first day of jail then ask me wait
what's the first thing I do when you're
in jail I don't know you're yeah I put
all the homies up and say he likes he
likes it rough all good all good but now
you're in jail first day what are you
doing big Friends making friends I heard
you're supposed to keep to yourself
uh-huh they say keep yourself somebody
and wait someone approaches you
it's it's me Duff it's gonna be tough
because I don't look white sure as hell
not black yeah I'd be Latino Latino you
gotta find out you ain't well am I we
don't do we don't do 21s of me oh
they'll find out and then what happens
is they they find out through the
podcast that you're white as [__] you're
Italian now you're in California you're
what's called uh
a wood a wood yeah now you got two
choices you can join the a b area and
Brotherhood
or you're a wood you regular guy okay
you can't be in the middle now the ab's
coming for you and they need an enforcer
and they need a guy who's down for the
call I'm gonna have to use my skill
setting and they need you to get you
you're gonna have probably gonna start
you're gonna have to get some kind of a
swastik on your ass or something oh dude
you mean on my face dude you can't
you're gonna be you're gonna be a giant
enforcer and it's all good I'm gonna
hate my life it's what I have to do to
make the ends meet yeah gotta do it for
the Little Debbie cakes in the
commissary that's right not to get my
eyes played with all the time yeah now
now I'm older
chances I'm probably going to be left
alone I'm not going to be a b because
they're going to be like man you know
but I might get you might be you might
be one of those kind of opportunists
where they see and like might as well
it's all we got today and they're gonna
they're gonna [__] proper [__] me
Robert yeah they're gonna fill you up no
it's not possible they'll fill you up
not possible though yeah Philadelphia
hey hey get the old man let's fill them
up and and and hey little man running
low I'll admit I gotta I got an apple
bottom and I'm a good looking man so I'm
gonna open your Peach up dude first
first my shaving down a little bit first
am I shave me down you're gonna get
dealt with before I do it is that right
sexual so here's the thing here's the
difference in you and me your mouth
here's what you don't understand your
mouth is terrible though no it's not my
mouth you [__] you don't think so now
your teeth your teeth look like a
[__] bear trap so anybody puts it a
little bit yourself
I got a nice mouth I got a nice mouth
don't be a dick I have I have nice lips
and nice mouth but here's the thing
here's what I'm doing I'm in my I'm in
my cell and I'm sharpening I'm
sharpening the two you're making Shanks
I'm sharpening my toothbrush and then
I'm going to get some salt and put it in
my orange juice and I'm just gonna stir
so when a big old so when the a b
recruits you to put it down because
they're going to be like we got to break
your spirit you're oh boy your old boy
ranks we need you to get up in his guts
you're that old Wild Horse we got to
break you in yep because I'm still I'm
like yeah and I'm just sitting in my
thing and I'm like please don't no and
you come at me and I go please the salt
in your eyes and you're like what and
then gank gang gang and I jab your
throat then that's one then the rest of
the calvary's come behind no then they
go how the [__] did you like that bro
let's jump them in he thinks things
through
and everybody's gonna get poked I'm
gonna do one better ah tell you it has
to be the first thing I do I'm trans
now that's a good idea sorry I identify
as a Rouge on give me a wig and
transforming the women in prison no
nobody messing with me you're having a
lot of sex you should all you and then
also someone getting pregnant a lot of
people can't practice oh yeah I'm being
real styling out there well yeah because
because Hungry Eyes walks in there
because soon as they go shoulders for
days as soon as they go lights off
ladies oh thank God I take it all off
and they're like oh my I'm like yeah
it's all ruse I'm just here to [__]
anybody want to cuddle yeah who else is
lonely dude who wants to cuddle and then
I bet you there's some good looking
women in prison for oh haven't you ever
seen the mug shots like the baddies oh
yeah there's some there's some there's
some attractive bring up some baddies in
prison just Google attractive inmates
because then what I would do is I would
have my daddy I'd be like Dad I really
need you to fill up the commissary card
I get a bunch of little Debbies I give
that to the Head security guy like put
me in there with a dime right
right
and and the problem is he gets in
trouble if somebody gets pregnant so you
need oh not man not man not man I just
did inmates so yeah that guy that guy
got a lot of uh attention he made a
billionaire yep he did yep and he did
have a dime piece of the billionaire he
did have a dime piece it left her nice
with a billionaire is that true he's
like a legit model but he's a
billionaire
oh see he that was his girl on the right
now he bounced to some older like
billionaire girls love a bad boy what
was he in for
you being beautiful
damn
yeah I do this
yeah but he left this girl who stood by
him and now he just says
that's a good looking man
he has mug shot went like viral and he
got all these endorsements
that's who he's with now
he's just I think they might have broken
up though hot felon yeah oh they broke
up I think so why because he kept
stealing stuff yeah she's she's uh very
happy I mean she's she's a regular gal
done up God bless her but oh she didn't
have that money she has no yeah she out
kicked her coverage there he's a stud is
he skinny yeah I want him to be jacked
no okay
but he's uh there he is he's doing well
there you go he's doing well
it's like having a pet Pit Bull right
well that's what's hot though yeah I'm
saying they're fun they're fun till they
start doing pit bull [__] I mean yeah he
comes up hard he's fun she's fun look at
her she's a sweet little gal
God bless her
taking care of his man oh dude loving
him loving him the dude wants to know
stories about jail he's dangerous
she's forced forced him to watch 60 days
in all the time oh bad boy is this what
it's like wear leather I know you don't
want to but do it anyway
dude just sit on that motorcycle I'll
buy you one
that's not at all that's dark go back to
the ladies for us chin yeah thanks Chen
thanks for no I'm just saying
um
yeah what was he in for do we know chin
let's see
let's just go to his uh hopefully it's
fist fighting
you can't just Google yeah
arrest and viral popularity uh Arista
Meeks and three other men in a
multi-aging law enforcement Mission
dubbed operation ceasefire Meeks was the
weapon convicted felon arrested failing
weapon Charters denies the charges
within 24 hours when the mug shots were
posted 200 Pages photo had acquired more
than 15 000 likes 3 700 Comics mostly
from women
of course yeah of course definitely gay
men too
#failing Crush Friday in honor of Meek's
mug shot all I was was just transporting
guns that's manly the spokesman for the
uh Stockton Police Department said the
mugshot had received more attention than
any other mug shot since they launched
face launched their Facebook page in
2012. yeah no [__] 13 months of a
sentence
that is better though right just gun
like and then became much oh how [__]
great is that eye color blue gray [__]
bro I'm an actor I can use those [__]
looks
I would have been on a on a show like
SWAT or something you think get down
yeah you know something like did he get
into acting too
probably tried oh he wrote a book called
Model citizen it wasn't me
it was Oliver the same [__] was in me I
live hard I live hard I kiss hard too
can't think about me as I live hard I
kiss hard and I [__] hard are those as
kids no no no no no are they I think
they are yeah let's hear what year this
is though nothing but white girl 2016.
nothing but whites across the board he
seems like a sweet kid who knows look
let's take a little break Brandon all
right because it's about unique health
benefits and it's about being able to
eat something that's delicious you
talking about nuts buttery I'm all about
nuts you love nuts in your mouth I'm
talking about macadamias lowering net
carbs the most popular nuts they're low
33 less than almonds 50 less than
cashews they have arguably the best fat
profile of any nut like avocado on
steroids okay they have more money on
that saturated fat
um they've got uh they've got Omega
seven fatty acids which can support
natural collagen production glucose
metabolism and reduce inflammation and
they're really good for satiety so if
you're trying to lose weight you eat a
couple of macadamia nuts they make you
feel full they're also ridiculously
delicious which is why they're the most
expensive and rarest of nut but House of
macadamia is working vertically with 90
plus farmers in South Africa in these
communities when they're struggling
economies so you say macadamia that's
just aren't for the rich anymore dude no
dude and you're you're getting farmer
can they dip them in some a little bit
of chocolate for Me Maybe white
chocolate like I got regular chocolate
regular chocolate raspberry vanilla
macadamia nut bars which are delicious
how about the creamy Nut Butter fresh
from the Harvest don't you start on the
extra virgin Macadamia Oil oh my god
dude
buttery flavor it's delicious high smoke
point great we're doing a special
discount right now for the fine kid Army
for limit time they're giving you guys a
free box of the 45 Macadamia snack bars
they're delicious one of each flavor you
get the variety pack then choose then
order your own when you visit
houseomeacademias.com tfak you get 20
off your entire order with the code tfak
House of macadamias they're nutty
they're nuts
what's this
who makes
contacts
OS model out of prison that makes uh
that's our boy Trevor Wallace yeah this
is from his podcast
yeah this is in prison bro
asked if you have any guys weapons how
do I get locked up you know what's so
funny is why is she wearing the same
thing in every tick tock because she's
in prison jail but imagine your bug mate
is making tick tocks and you're like I'm
in here from martyr can you can we not
do this yeah I killed one person it's
about to be two stop dude if I'm a guard
that's my favorite event right there you
can eat however much caviar do you want
dude bro I'm just gonna do 25 to wife
dog
25 to wife son she murdered somebody I
mean I'm obviously out look up that girl
chin not their commentary let's see what
the hot inmate is
food they give you in prison too God the
diet's awful I know I would imagine
although my buddy's a prison there's a
bunch of slots and uh uh talks buddy and
uh it's been a prison guard forever and
he said uh you can get everything in
there everything you want good at the
commissary yeah whatever I don't know if
you need good food oh my god oh Lordy
boy
yeah that's not that she's in there for
murder at all
no she's probably in there for some drug
[__]
oh what I'd say looks like she's in
there for smuggling some melons am I
right
I'm guessing it might be it could be you
a mountain Smuggler
all right well
well let me see some other prison bags
gave her three years yeah let's see some
other prison baddies because I like uh I
like a little bit of roughness on the
face could you do it be like let's say
you met your girl and you didn't know in
like two years I'm sorry two weeks into
dating you're at dinner she's like I
gotta get this off my chest 100 I just
got out I did 100 now hold on I did a 15
year stamp for what
listen I grew up in Georgia and
it was just a different time and I hung
a black guy well
really not good well you're the one
saying 100 yeah
is no no no no but she's like but I went
to prison I'm completely different and I
found I Found Jesus Christ yeah but me
my friends I I didn't no no I did buy
the Rope I'll give you that and I did
pick the guy out no I'm afraid I can't
you wouldn't do it what if she's like
I'm completely my my um
what in the world is going on here
prison seeing some beautiful girls hey
here for jail hey all right right what
do you mean like the redhead with the
chin Quagmire down there but look at the
one up there they're all gorgeous
they're all right that the second one in
the top two they're bottom two I think
they're all painfully hot but I'm just
getting older so any it all the older
you get like they're all gorgeous to me
you know yeah I guess I'm not there yet
Becky with the bangs what are we doing
bottom right I'm happy she has those
stupid bangs I like Becky Banks Becky
bangs yeah I like them all but B what
like at what what what what crime are
you okay like let's murder no it depends
all right self-defense yeah right let me
do this one no self-defense
I will agree so so if I if you let me
give you let me give you one let me give
you one yeah two weeks in your girl's
like ah this is getting pretty serious
how you get this off my chest yeah
I uh I was babysitting three kids and it
was a hot summer day in Calabasas and I
now listen listen hold on hold on she
goes and don't hurt the kid no hold on
hold on all right and you know I thought
the windows were down and I I had to
take a [__] like I was about to [__] my
pants I rushed in I was in there way
longer I come out kids are dead and they
they gave me 15 years man and I regret
it every day of my life and I want kids
now kids die for God's just from heat
stroke and I had no idea I was in there
so long I lost time [__] my brain's out
she's just dumb can we deal with them
yeah I can deal with dumb so you're
still okay it's a tragedy that you know
but but she's like and here's the kicker
I want three kids okay let me ask you
this question here's a better one here's
a better this is so dark
the first one the first one's hard to
deal with I found a black guy yeah well
yeah I did you know that that was I
didn't know we were going Ku Klux plan
here
she used to be no no I can't do it now
if I'm having sex and she tells me while
we're having sex
I don't even have to finish and then
we'll talk yeah she could confess to her
she's like we're breaking up now she
could be like I'm the Golden State
killer I do like wait hold on I thought
this dirty talking let me get down like
I'm sorry I was in the middle of just
going to Pound Town yeah I'm kind of go
over what you said you're the Golden
State killer she's like yeah got away
with it for a long time there's a girl I
dated that I want to see what your
reaction would be I dated her
um she was really cool and I knew I
wasn't probably gonna it wasn't serious
but I liked her and she was great
and we got to talking about turning
tricks and how some girls and she she
said I used to do that
and she didn't like that like get over
on John's she just no shoes that's how
we talk on the street I'm sorry
a hooker so she goes I used to do that I
said for how long she goes like three
years but what's that like on the street
like walking down Figaro in downtown
okay that's high class the way she said
it she goes um I go what was that like
she was just sex I can separate it but
you know made money and that's the way
she said it the way she said it she was
so honest I had zero judgment I would
never have it wouldn't have gotten I
don't care it wouldn't have gotten you
heard jelly roll talk about his girl he
said on Rogan he's like listen she was a
high escort model like a high escort
high price high-priced escort like and
they asked like he's the most famous
people that tried goldfish like Eminem
like all these big names but jelly was
like when I met her that's what she was
doing and he was like I was okay with it
and she she would make sure I got my
daughter like paid for the legal uh
custody battle all that he's like so I
know she was down she's still doing that
[__]
I get it doesn't mean she's a bad person
do you know how many do you know how
many high-class prostitutes end up
marrying one of their religions and
stays my statements
that has kids married for him there
women are smart who go I've got this
crazy body I can separate sex from
emotion I'm gonna make a lot of money
but I'm I'm quietly hunting for a
billionaire who's gonna get addicted to
me boom well it's the same thing like
those Instagram thoughts when they
finally get with like a Zion Williams
Williamson or like a big name they get
pregnant like yeah I get it that's right
especially maybe there's a bond like but
also people are like oh what a [__] she
did on purpose or she's been doing this
with a ton of guys just so happens she
got pregnant she's like he's actually a
good dude too he's not a bad guy to get
in it's it's not surprising that a girl
that would get attached to Zion
Williamson or somebody else doesn't seem
like the smartest guy in the world but
he's probably pretty cool probably cool
dick I'm sure I'm sure he's I'm sure
he's not worse than I am in bed probably
not worse than I am in bed no right and
then also for those girls grinding out
there and just sucking every dick left
and right it's probably a relief it'd be
like me selling my whiskey like I don't
have to do 10 000 podcasts
I don't have to suck Ten Thousand Days
let's be honest we are horse my acting
teacher used to say this girl was
playing a hooker and he goes uh boy you
got a real judgment on hookers and she
goes yeah I guess and he goes you ever
do a job it looks at the whole class
anybody ever do a job just for money
everyone you're all [__] well on World
Star Hip-Hop they always post like the
hookers off a Figaro off yeah la and
like God damn we need to figure out bro
I mean seriously tense no ten stop it I
mean I would get robbed if I went down
there but tens you got to know the lay
of the land but you don't want to go
down when you're nice cars but you could
make a deal well let me see really on
the road dude no go to uh hookers on
Figaro hookers on Figueroa I mean just
hands too I mean our speed B I think
it's Figaro it'll do oh there it goes
this is the top one I would go to images
sure
all right let's go to images
I wonder if it's gonna
no they're definitely not that one
you're gonna get some weird ones no I'm
not talking about the trolls chin
brought up uh go back [__] because
these women look terrible listen you're
gonna get some warlocks
yep no don't go to image go back this
one yeah let's see what that does
hey guys I'm Milad I'm a documentary
maker in the field of social issues well
now I'm starting to see what you mean
yeah I'm telling you like Worldstar post
somebody like what is happening so much
have a farm
[Music]
a lot of gang activity down there a lot
of rough characters okay there you go
okay that looks like jelly roll it's
your girl all right that's your
girlfriend though
no one needs to eat okay this doesn't
help my case sir well
ooh in the rain working the brains snow
or a shot tough job right there that
look at that you have a problem with
that what in the world how she how is
she not getting picked up please that's
on Sandy what in the world
yeah that's uh that's a tough job that's
a tough [__] job though
you're walking you're working yeah be
careful though because they gotta take
their pimp the car and all that and
sometimes it's a it's a guy
well we'll navigate those Waters but
yeah we have a friend remember it was
like
some girl came to his thing and he goes
her hands were real big yeah feet and
hands yeah it's like I might have been
um all right okay
they're in the hood so it depends it's a
disaster that's kind of oh it's tough if
that's your daughter you're like God
well that's your life there like that's
not her ass is hanging out yeah
I don't even know where that that's
outside downtown did you live downtown
you never I've never passed by this
stuff New York City used to have this in
the 90s 80s and 90s yeah and then they
got rid of it right
I think I thought they were institutions
I thought they made it legal in New York
yeah well on the street on the West Side
Highway there was an area where it would
it was a thing you would go there to
look at them like even purse and they
were I get it hot in lingerie some of
them were ridiculous chin bring up we're
prostitutions legal I'm pretty sure New
York's legal
obviously Reno Nevada is legal that's
why the Bunny Ranch was there
I don't know it's not legal everywhere I
know it's dark arts since humans
illegals throughout California a lot
yeah California for sure but it's legal
is the only U.S jurisdiction yeah can I
go up go back up for a second let me
just see what his classified as
um acts of prostitution
yeah thousand dollars first offense add
to the bill
well I'll tell them I'll give you a
grand if I get Cuts another grand so
it's a risk
that's a thousand dollars I'm paying it
anyway yeah and possibly six months in
County Jail they're not doing whatever
happens yeah you immersed so even she's
a little bit in the face in L.A and they
get slapped on the wrist well yeah
so just Nevada only Nevada that's a
bummer interesting my buddy did a
documentary on the Bunny Ranch and he
said what's the one what's the one thing
every prostitute in there
said there's one thing all of them said
all every so when you interviewed them
it's the one through line that all of
them said about prostitution about what
they were doing it makes them sad nope
keep calling they have drug problems
nope they're shitty dads no they have no
dad uh no it was the one thing that all
of them said so their their prostitutes
I'm a prostitute but
but I can separate the like the no
but
every single one of them said
that uh they all do anal only temporary
oh oh yeah every stripper says same
thing I'm only doing this for a little
while until I and actually you know six
years goes by you're like [__]
well you get forced out that's the
bottle service girls too like just
temporary but they're making so such
good money which is tough yeah until
they're all hey leather face yeah gigs
up we gotta bring in the young tripping
is that way that's what I'm saying
that's the point where you just no
longer can do it that's with anything
though I mean besides a nine to five
like sports you only got you got a short
shelf life I was thinking about that I
was stripping running back in the NFL
nowadays oh right even the top running
backs like uh uh
saquon Barkley like the running back's
not like a a very I mean 30 right well
30 you become Scrooge McDuck but they
were saying like the top running backs
like saquon Barkley's work one of the
best running backs in the league but to
be just straight running back the
leagues like we didn't get anybody to do
it because the Passing League now so
saquan's like I'm a big deal I can catch
and do it all but you guys use me pay me
like I'm one of the top guys and New
York's they're they're holding out like
let's just get somebody else dude
because you probably got another two
years how much you get beat up you know
yeah like the run back position they
just don't value it like they used to
yeah and like run back not the
superstars aren't the running backs we
just hear about you know everybody from
Cadillac you got to be different though
you got to be yeah super old school
right but you gotta it's different now
like the like tomorrow uh for the Saints
um McCaffrey for the Niners
um you have all those Eckler for the
Chargers they got to be able to catch
and like they got to be able to catch
them so wow like like mccaff
oh is that what it is way more
entertaining so then they they actually
skew the game to viewership uh I think
it just happened naturally too
look at the NBA like Steph Curry changed
the NBA because everyone's to shoot now
like before it used to be a big man
League yeah Duncan now there's no big I
mean joke is the biggest guy dominating
yeah but other than that it's all
Shooters like Steph Curry changed the
game Patrick Mahomes change the game
Aaron Rodgers they changed joking just
just unreal nobody can touch somebody's
talking about how Serbia has I think
seven million people and the two best
athletes in the world in some ways well
Djokovic tennis player and how good is
that guy doing jokes he's like Larry
Bird or something right better Lady Bird
yeah yeah I mean the best the best yeah
the best not faster not just it's not
explosive not fast you just not like
you're smart as [__] like you know
LeBron explode and then chill he just
keeps it no matter how the game's going
he's at a seven all the time doesn't get
tired prefers to pass than school you
don't want to tell me it doesn't matter
if he scores three points or 30 points
as long as his team as long as he wins
he'd rather have well it's really joke
it's you'd rather have more system
points so he'll take care of everybody
like Murray's a good player he ain't
[__] without jokic he's just another guy
in the league well jokic makes him so
much better and did Joe they have to
focus he kind of like blossomed this
year no he won MVP last year he didn't
win MVP okay he won the MVP the past two
years this year David Joel embiid which
is hilarious
he grew up chubby you know I saw it but
he got drafted on the second round not
explosive not athletic not fast his
fundamentals are ridiculous and then his
IQ Second To None seven seven feet who's
whose muscles over there
it's gone look at the size of Djokovic
that's Dwight Howard he ain't [__]
computer
no joke itches in six two Joe gets a six
eleven no he's almost seven five yeah
Djokovic right there that that's the
best time oh yeah
look at the size of those [__] guys
joke is actually isn't number one
anymore yeah that's true
you have a joke it's interesting because
again if you're a young kid growing up
like
he doesn't jump the highest doesn't
Sprint the fastest he's just
fundamentals so then how do you use this
is his IQ
how do you
so when you talk about athlete he's a
good athlete he's a great athlete right
he's a he's a once in a generational
Talent as far as basketball goes but
he's not the best athlete okay but how
different athlete though he's he's he
will support like basketball but he
doesn't jump the highs but so does Tom
Brady the worst Athlete on the field I
know so how do they just play that game
he's the best too that no Wayne grets
he's a freak he's the fastest guy he's a
freak [__] freak at 17 he's playing
with grown men scoring a million dollars
he's a freak that's a bad example but
Joe kids again he's the best at
basketball he understands basketball
better than anybody else on the court he
knows exactly what people are going to
do yeah he's like Floyd I don't think I
don't think Floyd Mayweather was the
best athlete right box and he knows
exactly what punch he's gonna throw you
have to put IQ in there game IQ is part
of being an athlete but but it's
different like is Dwight Howard a better
athlete than jokic yeah but he's not as
tough not as durable doesn't know the
game as well done with tenacity could
you to apply the same thing to fighting
uh meeting like athletes yeah I mean
like these are certain guys who are good
at fighting you know anything else they
can't do GSP or something
what I thought was I was always told
Wayne Gretzky was the slowest skater
[__] no and then I saw him do a foot
race when he was older against like put
could Wayne Gretzky in a foot race and I
was like wait a minute this doesn't make
sense he's a freak it's like David on
the on the Houston Oilers I'm not
Houston Oilers the Edmonton Oilers watch
this hold on one Wayne Gretzky 100 meter
sprint so he's racing
bjornborg he's racing hold on who are
the athletes Pele Pele look at look at
Wayne
starchism look at that I don't think
Wayne gretzee is known for being slopy
like he was so fast apparently not
because he's a freak wait a minute
those guys sucked at running but yeah
let's take a break I want to talk about
supplements and the best supplements
I'll plan on let me guess on it Brian I
want to talk about Focus I'm talking
about increasing your cognitive function
your Memory Alpha Brain Alpha Brain
instant Alpha Brain about mental Clarity
Focus shot pre-workout I only use Alpha
Brain black man it's the highly
concentrated Alpha Brain now everybody
else gets the regular Alpha Brain
they've sold over a million bottles you
know it's the number one nootropic on
the planet but Alpha Brain Black is
turbo for your brain try it they have
the focus shot the Pre-Workout the
instant Alpha Brain it's the number
nootropic you get your money back
guaranteed if you don't love it but
you're well if you need uh supplements
you need freaking protein powders
creatines glutamines you need freaking
MCT oil Warrior bars fat Butters and
then workout gear we got kettlebells on
it sandbags Hydro Core bags they got all
streaming Fitness for your thick ass
literally summer everything on it.com
f-a-t-k and you get 10 off the entire
site including Alpha Brain Black instant
all the alpha brains the focus the
pre-workouts and all the things we just
told you about it's on it baby onit.com
f-a-t-k temp South everything let's give
birth to the program
that is that's the same video too late
apart and Sugar Ray Leonard
I figured Pele would be the one we keep
up with him now I don't know how old is
video that's impressive it's all right
yeah I figured you beat him yeah then
you put skates I have to do you know if
you never Sprint at all not really I
hate when people say that no no it's not
no it's not I hate when people say that
no it's true no it's not if you don't
Sprint if you're just a boxer and you're
never Sprint even if you could be faster
from the day you're born you know how to
use it you're either faster you're not
there's 100 you can get with any trainer
in the world that's right it doesn't
matter
explosion sprinting and you have the
same Talent you know sometimes you're
going to be faster if you like if you
just run a race and the guy never
Sprints but if you have the same talent
I think that you know you're going to
get your body's kind of used to it
you're going to be more explosive takes
a guy a second but yeah
you've been around your entire life your
entire hate wouldn't be like there's
this kid on my son's team and he's so
slow he's awful he's not like what are
we doing he's not very fast the coach
went to the dad's like you know I got a
Sprint coach if he works on this kicking
be really fast no he can't no dad's like
you sound like he doesn't have it 100
you teach them all mechanics anybody you
see in the pros now none of them would
have to be taught how to run fast that's
right we all know how to write it
naturally Sports jeans
look to that he goes there's never been
a case where a kid was slow like in
soccer or football and and they worked
with a coach and became fast
and you're running you can get look
there's a lot of technique to sprinting
so if you want to be a printer and track
you better work with a coach because if
you have just talent and the other guy
has talent he's going to beat you up
everyone's fasting at that level but but
I'm but I mean but you are you're not
going to be unless you have it no matter
what you do you'll never run in 100
meter sprint in the Olympics it's never
happened
it's not how to happen it's like people
some people have you know rhythm
some people don't there's nothing we can
do it's the way you were born I have
rhythm yeah you've ever been on the
dance floor yeah kind of but it's you
know it's like there's nothing we can do
either have it or you don't so there's
no coach in the world that's going to
teach you to [__] dance like Chris
Brown since we're on the topic of sports
oh yeah UFC 290 we haven't talked about
this is going to be all I've talked
about on the shop show all right no I'm
down I love your opinion because we had
Dom Cruz on one-on-one today he's a
great Dom Cruz yeah he breaks it down
he's such a [__] brilliant dude he's
the best and did he have yeah which
fight
well bring up the card because you want
to talk yeah you're just the main card
there's five great fights I'm never ever
betting against volkanovsky again even
if he has a broken leg because he's
such a champion he's just different he's
different now now at 145 pounds if
there's anybody that has a chance to
beat
greatness which is vulcanovsky it's
yario Rodriguez my thing is like if you
watch volkanovski when it when he went
against makachev even though he lost
that fight I went oh 145 is screwed I
mean he's like you think yeah 155 could
be screwed I mean exactly yeah but the
145 good luck everybody I don't care who
you are now yair is the best feather way
on the planet not named volkonoski yes
but volkanovsky's there that's what
happens yeah so Gusman Jon Jones guess
one was the best dual fiber walk in this
[__] planet yeah not named John I
will say volcanov's I mean yair
Rodriguez is a buzz saw and I think his
style is very hard to prepare for I feel
like his style how do you get guys guys
beat him though and there's a blueprint
to beat him take him down wear them out
first two rounds third and fourth go to
work you drain his energy so he's not as
explosive so don broke down great he
goes what's interesting is what
what um volkanasi had to do against
makachev because what's machev do he
gives you he pressures you get you
against cage takes you down hold you
down pounds you down is comfortable in
guard and what Alexander volkanovski
want to do is defend the takedown get
back to the middle of the octagon and
beat him up kick him create distance
well yair has to do the exact same thing
to avoid the takedown don't get taken
down keeping the middle lock gun trying
to get that knocked out
vulcanovski has to do exactly what mock
Jeff did against him high pressure give
me a schedule he goes it's all going to
depend who puts together the better game
plan who can defend the takedown
[Music]
striking is so otherworldly like this is
so good yeah now it's just oh she's not
doing it wrong world class yeah but
that's that's when I say better I mean
it's yay Rodriguez only chance the more
to deal with yeah but it's his only
chance to win he's knocking out grapple
him he's not going to submit him down
there yeah but not he's too good in the
guard yeah so he has to be able to
control in the middle Octon and hope he
can land something his only chance to
win I don't think he wins I think
voganovski beats the [__] out of him if
there's any 45 pounder that's going to
win it he's the only guy but I just you
know there's a reason why I broke it up
to the minus four fish after the market
Jeff thing I was like I'm never betting
against volkanovsky and then you know I
say this on the shop show but the the
entire main card is it should be UFC 290
mismatches really
Bo nickel is like a minus seven thousand
now he's fighting this that valve wood
burn he's so his original original
opponent Bo Nichols dropped out he got
hurt this week who was it trejon Gore
ever heard him doesn't matter so with
Val Woodburn he was supposed to be on
Dana White Contender series 7-0 comes
off the local circuit they go hey we
know you're gonna do Dane white
Contender series jacked huh sure doesn't
matter they're gonna say instead of
Daniel white condemna series here's Bo
nickel here's your chance to get in the
UFC you might you're probably not going
to win this one but we promise you
whatever two or three fights after this
that's all right put it because I mop
the floor with him but so I'm just gonna
grab him and wrestle him doesn't matter
or do whatever he wants but then Jalen
Turner Dan hooker tough fight for hooker
Jalen Turner is a [__] then
hooker needs this one though then Robert
Whittaker uh do policies Whitaker is the
best middleweight of all time not name
uh Izzy the thing about this Whitaker
hasn't lost a fight since 2014 to
anybody but two fights to Izzy he's beat
everybody else since 2014. I would argue
he lost to uh I mean I would argue he
lost that fight too uh yo Romero but
yeah nobody won it no yes still want it
but it doesn't matter still they want it
it's amazing I didn't realize he's only
lost dancing that's [__] I did not
realize last guy to beat him before that
was uh Wonder Boy he did not realize
that 2014 dude that's so that's how good
he is that's so important everybody else
that's unbelievable that's [__] crazy
that he did and then Don pointed out
some Wars by the way
he's starched a lot of guys like it's
he's getting better that's what's scary
about him so he's getting better you'd
say and then do policies it's like
hasn't fought the same guys there's a
reason why they're doing it like it's a
win-win for the UFC and down pointing
this out he goes it's a win-win because
Robert Whittaker wins like Robert
Whittaker Izzy cell is the highest live
gate of all times that makes sense for
the UFC if duplicity wins you get two
Africans fighting there's a narrative
there we can sell that I just I I can't
think of a worse matchup for duplicates
there's the worst man he he really
hasn't beat anybody and then Robert
Whittaker just stylistically it's a
night why are they doing that it's just
a tune it's a win no it's not a [__]
tune-up the tune-up for whoever no [__]
no the police is number six in the world
he beat Derek Brunson beat there until
but in those he was losing both of those
fights and came back but Robert
Whittaker is a [__] man
and for the UFC like like Don said it's
a win-win for whoever wins that they can
build the next content and Frenzy then
Bram Moreno pantosha you know who
pantosia beat right no mock Chef knock
them out
oh never heard of him time ago doesn't
matter still knocked them out
yeah that's how bad that [__] is
damn
and then and then also you know this be
he's beat ramarano twice
he beat him in 2017 they beat him on The
Ultimate Fighter beat him twice dude
isn't that crazy he's 2-0 against Brian
Moreno damn
um Robbie Lawler still fighting this is
his last fight it is yep
that's his swan song this is his last
one at 170 or 85 170.
this could be hard for him to get down
to 170. no he's been fighting at seven
thick is a tick no he's been fighting
70b professional it's his last fight
this is retirement somebody said they
saw him and he was he wasn't used it was
hanging out with them and they were like
they're like how much do you weigh not
me I've been on cardboard about 220. I
buy cars with Rob he's not a big dude
yeah
hmm
Jack Della uh Jack Dell is a Savage have
you been I've been watching we need him
to look tough just a little would you
say I mean what episode
on there I'm a huge Connor fan but man
yeah they're 0-6 yeah and he and maybe
it's the editing he's never around yeah
I know and all when he is around it he's
just pushing his product I'm like man if
they thought this was gonna help Conor
out and get this suit it's it's it's
it's it's gone bad yeah it looks like
he's coming he just came from a meeting
and he's standing there yeah
but what they had won the cast from The
Ultimate Fighter on he was like he goes
maybe they're edit so Conor's not there
he's never there in the morning practice
but he's at every night practice
not bad but he's not at weigh-ins which
is weird
the problem is he's always six but the
other issue is the format of the show
that's versus rookies is terrible idea
and the Rookie's all been getting
crushed they're not even competitive
it's Owen six bad idea huh I said that
from the jump but soon so I'm like ah
what are they doing those poor kids
yeah and kind of whenever he's on he's
like promoting fast or his whiskey like
oh this is just a commercial form it's a
commercial and then Chandler cares and
he also has the talent so Chandler looks
great
you know I mean I love Connor I'm just
like God has training yeah he's training
yeah yeah
you know he's not fine this year he's
not who knows if that fight happened uh
listen your boy Elon Musk is training
dude
yeah you don't think it's gonna happen I
still don't think the fight happens a
good chance it does I mean I don't I
don't know it's gonna be interesting
because Mark and the other thing what
makes it interesting is Mark Zuckerberg
is launching that new competition to
Twitter I just got an email today from
him I forget what it's called what's
called chin I'll look it up thanks
that'd be great
um he has that uh what is it
um
not meta medicine
he has a new thing yeah oh right he's
got a Twitter red threads they said I
got an email today from the heads of
threads to get early access to it
so we'll see how that goes well it's
gonna compete with Twitter what are the
uh what are the parameters are you uh do
you have to be do you have to give a
woke card do you no no I don't think so
who knows but it's there it's there it's
their way to take on Twitter Whoever has
issues with Twitter
so that makes this fight even more
compelling because he's launching that
pretty impressive I guess he has
billions of dollars I mean this guy's
the limit just more more apps a lot of
people are gonna go over there though
you think so I mean the left is they
hate Twitter
even though they want freedom of speech
then they get mad when it's freedom of
speech Yeah Tim Poole was talking about
I think he was he was him talking about
how they're going to be I liked him as
we get more and more divided there's
going to be a parallel parallel Banks
parallel social media like the left and
right parallel economy like two lanes
yeah parallel economy enjoy that some
people make more money over here other
people make more money over here that's
how it is though so I will be talking to
each other that's not good I don't think
so that's not good right now they're not
talking to each other right now people
just I was at a I was at a [__]
dinner party and all I did was bring up
the fact that my kid was being taught
from the anti-racist handbook and that I
had read all the critical race theorists
or a lot of them and I had an argument I
didn't want my 11 year old having to
deal with that and being told that he
was at 11. a dominant patriarchal
oppressive box he occupied that box when
he's 11. he's got a so he should have
guilt at 11. yeah and I had a and
they've chose the wrong person because
I've done my homework
and I went to the teacher and I said oh
no I know that I think you're saying you
had dinner well I was at it's dinner
party and the couple I found out were
very liberal and they left
because she didn't even say bye she just
left come over and goes God I leave you
alone and you end up driving people like
I didn't say I didn't have a
conversation I was literally having a
conversation and I was open to any kind
of talk I I thought it was an
interesting thing because they were
bringing up something but that's part of
the problem like we can't even discuss
it and then engage with me well that's
Libs right that's that's the left yeah
wow it actually made me feel really bad
you shouldn't I was like because that's
all of them they have no they have no
backbone man so when you you give them
facts like what are you talking about
what are you talking about they can't
they yeah and then I I was talking about
how I went and did that SWAT training
where you get tased and you're you're
learning how to shoot active shooter
stuff you know and they they were
offended by it and I was like I was just
telling you that you go to dinner with
them I was that I got invited by good
friends and then they had their friends
there and most of the people were great
but this couple were just different you
know thank God see ya it was a thing
good riddance it was a thing they left
and say Good Riddance [__] oh and
they were my age they weren't young now
imagine that's your Mom and Dad wow hey
Dad why did you leave dinner I just I
couldn't argue with him it's too
masculine and I should have picked up on
it the guy said I I can't do this right
now you know something and I was like
what I didn't double down what do you
mean what can't you do have a discussion
I wasn't saying anything crazy well I'm
also open-minded man if you have better
ideas I'd love to hear because maybe you
can change it's fun I want to hear it
like me too I'm not gonna die in the
hill on this and the affirmative action
change my mind affirmative action
changed my mind there's nothing more
racist than affirmative action and the
college system it's a great discussion
it's not even a discussion there
couldn't be more racism involved than
that decision so let me let me get this
straight you want to make it so easy for
African-Americans get into school that
they're taking the lower 30 percent of
African-Americans and then the the
Asians and whites who are at the top 10
are getting in but the lower thirds the
African-Americans are so what you're
saying to me it sounds like is you don't
think African-Americans can study and
learn and get better grades than these
other races how that isn't racist in any
facet is [__] there can be anything
more races that you don't think the guy
said this Asian guy said the average
Asian student has to get 273 points
higher on test scores
to get in than an African-American and
what we have to remember about this is
katenji Jackson Brown wrote about
uh African-Americans and their lived
experience and she was using
hypothetical situations where she
doesn't realize that Asian Americans
who've suffered no shortage no shortage
of suppression of Oppression
um they are the ones who were being
excluded and it was like well your your
color of your skin and that is a
violation of the Civil Rights Act yeah
yeah that doesn't make sense
affirmative action was always a very
tentative thing for our it was always
essentially illegal but they were like
with great discretion use race as one
factor of many and I guess what the
Asians do what Asians did is they went
uh Harvard's the best school UCLA John
Hopkins we gotta study more than anybody
make it a focus with our children in
order for them to be competitive against
everybody else and then [__] took
over that's how this stuff over there
actually they're actually lumping Asians
in with white people which is really
kind of of course
but then what happens if you're okay
with this Asian we're talking Chinese
Korean and Japanese but go on yeah yeah
it all falls on the same marker but then
also if if you do if you're okay with
this well let's take it over to
affirmative action across the board
let's go to sports man I watch
basketball there's a lot of black guys
that's not fair man we need some Jews in
there we need some white guys you're
like but the whites and Jews can't shoot
I know but they need the same
opportunity there's too many black
people on the on the court you're going
to pay for that product a a watered-down
product because you wanted to represent
more of your world worse your
perspective worse was looking at Harvard
and the communiques the emails they were
so like it's just like dude be more
blatant however there could be anything
more race however the one thing that um
the dissenters on the Supreme Court is
saying is how about Legacy I think 40 or
30 of their 40 of their their uh the
admissions are a legacy uh that's a
problem
endowment and apparently because those
parents will give money they go [__]
up too see but that's not affirmative
action yeah that's that those could be
any color we're not you cannot pick a a
student to get into school based off
their race
you can't you shouldn't even look at
their name you should just look at their
scores GPA he's in he's not who gives a
[__] what color there that is the market
value yeah so when when you go to the
doctor and let's say your your wife's
gonna have surgery
and affirmative action got this he got
his Doctorate but he's in the lower 30
percentile do you give a [__] what color
he is you want the best there is to save
this is my joke I always say if you're
gonna operate on my spine I want the
best I I don't care if the guy's a
cannibal I want the best and these
people sometimes [__] it you know you
don't care I just want the best I'm
colorblind but and that's that's why
Sports is great there's no affirmative
action yeah I love it the best of the
best well they're all black all Asian
all Jewish the best of the best it's a
it's that you'll hear your liberals talk
about someone's lived experience
and it's just like it's the most common
[__] you gotta remember the one thing I
hate about I'm white people are I've
been white people are annoying because
like white people will talk about the
lived experience of somebody and um and
what they're really saying is what what
my objection with like white liberals
especially academic liberals is we have
to get white people to change before
brown and black people can have a chance
so condescending it's so [__]
condescending yeah but and it's usually
because they don't really have a lot of
like Clarence Thomas who's uh high up he
goes I hate affirmative action because
he went to Columbia or whatever he goes
now if I see somebody they have a degree
from Colombia with affirmative action I
go oh they were given that like they
didn't they didn't earn it so he goes it
it takes away from the hard work that I
it took for me to get in those schools
because now you see a black person
whoever it is that got a degree from
Harvard with affirmative action like oh
that's not a real degree like we know
like it's not but we broke it down this
way but also don't forget be with
affirmative action do not forget it's
just a numbers game nobody talks about
this group there are more poor white
people with less education less
resources than any other place in
America
you have you ever heard somebody stick
up for them ever do
it's not good there's poor there's way
it's just the numbers that's what is how
about Mexicans there's more poor
Mexicans there are poor blacks
do you hear any of them complaining
about affirm action any you ever hear
anybody sticking up for him raising
money for him any of this [__] no they
go to work
well I think I think a lot of black
people go to work of course too and I
think I'm not saying they don't a lot of
black people have a problem with
affirmative action in fact if you do
polls you'll see a great deal of
African-American voters you know
condescending it is a big problem to say
you guys can't you guys aren't smart
like the other people so we gotta dumb
it down for you most of the population
black brown he says it's these little
lights yeah
what the [__] are you talking about it's
with most of them are like and your
daddy's paid for your school and your
tutor what do you [__] you guys thought
you guys have no perspective yeah that's
why nobody listens to them
well the news is there to tell you how
things should be not how things are
every time I [__] hear that I've
watched the news I'm like what world do
you guys living in where are you living
I don't know who still watches the news
that's one of the reasons well why would
you it's all this sad stories show me
the world's on fire and I'm just living
my life you see they found cocaine at
the White House sure and now you can bet
on Whose it was uh Alex I'll take Hunter
Biden for 5 000 please and I'm just here
to say this I know he's a complete [__]
up it's a brief evacuation and I've said
this before he looks fun and dude he's a
[__] he looks like a Good Time Charlie
dude he's his dad left my computer you
imagine if that's your boy like if you
that's your buddy his dad is the leader
of the Free World this dude is filming
going in a 911 Turbo Porsche half meth
with hookers
he's a good time dude listen don't know
I'm running my country though I'm
negotiating policies for me with Ukraine
but as far as a Friday night who him or
Daryl strawberry it's a good [__]
time dude it's a good time I don't want
to babysit my kids I'm not saying that
one night in New York you give me one
person with unlimited money Hunter Biden
honor buying baby it's a good time dude
and we get away with everything
no we don't have to worry about any we
get pulled over whatever dude my dad
yeah
name somebody else you'd rather have a
wild night with Vegas dude it'd be some
fun buy the Bunny Ranch also he's Hunter
Biden you know he sells his paintings
for like half sure why not I know bring
up some of Hunter Biden's pain they're
so bad
bring them up because they sell for a
lot because rich people are like no they
they say they sell for a lot but
obviously it's his friends buying of
course to make it seem like it's selling
for a lot let's see let's see what we
think honestly
all right
go back up
these runs those aren't are those those
are our prints
four dollars it's not bad
see that one
it's pretty good like a bluebird I like
that blue bird and there's things it's
actually kind of here's what else makes
it more valuable probably did that on
Matthew Fox again more impressive I
agree look at them
he's in Venice I think I don't think so
no no he's definitely not in Venice
Brian there you go right there it's not
bad 225
000. that's bad can I paint that right
now sure I don't know that's pretty good
dude I could do that Hunter's kind of
talented I want I want one of his
paintings again goes back he seems like
a good time dude a little painting some
[__] a little cocaine yeah getting the
911 we fall into any issues call my
daddy Chopper us out yep not a not a bad
looking man how tall is he
I think Joe's about six too Biden that's
pretty tough he was
five eight there's no way right okay no
no yeah he's supposed to say six feet
nobody thinks he's tall this is Brian's
obsession with bigger men I knew he's
five seven five how tall uh Joe Biden is
maybe five eleven Joe Biden yeah
six six feet that's on there
current president six feet you shrank
when you get older yeah he's getting
smaller yeah might have been taller when
he was younger
Donald 6'3 Donald's a big boy Barack is
six two come on
wow who's the tallest is it eight
Lincoln I think
click on that chair if you go down yeah
Abraham Lincoln six four James Madison
it's fine and six four back then was a
beast
ah yeah
Ronald Reagan it's about six two I think
and what's interesting is too is uh Joe
Biden would acknowledge Hunter Biden's
son you know here's a kid dude he has a
relationship yeah he refuses yeah yeah
and and the girl was pretty attractive
bring that up chin Hunter Biden's baby
mama that is he was paying 10 grand a
month which is yeah chump change the
President should I just type in baby
mama yeah
foreign
ladies and gentlemen
yeah in the Bible Administration refused
to acknowledge her
is that right yeah
oh that's his daughter yep he's not in
her life nope oh that's so bad he's a
piece of [__]
he'll spend 20 grand a month but they
redid it where it was less
[__] that guy then
Hunter
yeah that's where you draw the line oh
yeah interesting be a dad you piece of
[__] I mean did you think he was a good
one dude he's on by the way you know
you're a good point maybe better to stay
out of the kid's life until you got it
together you get them right now so we're
driving 175 miles an hour with the kid
in baby seat imagine imagine this Donald
Trump I mean uh Bill Clinton does dick
suck no of office that's wild that's
wild hunter you're
your dad is the president United States
hey bro and there's all this
investigation going around you come to
the his house the White House with blow
and you snort cocaine at the table Yeah
gangster gangster again had an honest
person as he walked through the uh makes
me like
something about them like that is a math
likes to party he's a wild boy blowing
hookers not a terrible time there's a
price to pay not just money but I love
the screams daddy Biden wasn't in his
life
uh it's self-sabotage I'm trying to get
back at his dad I think Hunter so here's
what I have to say about all of this how
old was Hunter when he lost his mother
and two sisters at the same time and
loves his brother and then he lost his
brother now I'm sorry but that Survivor
guilt and and you and I have children
watch this this is going to make you
feel so bad for him
okay
God 72
Hunter was born in 70.
so he was two so he so two is a terrible
age who's your mommy and daddy you know
exactly here we didn't lose his dad now
you don't know exactly you're a mommy is
uh yeah you do my son's a year and a
half he lost his mom right now it'd be a
disaster he loves his mom they died and
then his brother died
2015 from brain cancer his brother
you're buying things he was an Iraq war
though
you hear me keep saying my son more than
all it's it's he's been through a lot
he's been through a lot
now I don't know
I don't know but I
he's been through a lot
you know
yeah the drug use I understand but not
not the
the stuff with China and all that stuff
and he had an addiction man he had a
[__] addiction and that's that grips
some people good P of course good people
and some people don't make it so I gotta
tighten it up though he's had every
resources pot your dad's the president
of the United States but he has
tightened it up now oh has he they just
found cocaine at the White House Brian
okay
how do we know it's his who I mean I'll
take five thousand Alex yeah 100 for
five thousand he's just a wild boy dude
wow 13 days without sleeping now smoking
crack drinking vodka yeah I don't
believe that but that's a long time
Melissa Cohen his book is about him
being sober I'm not buying that word
dude might as well buy [__] Puff the
Magic Dragon believe that it's like come
on
you hear him on Marin though and he
couldn't help but like him that's why I
was like oh he's a good time oh yeah
come on you and I would like him at the
end of the day we talked to him we got
to get him on the podcast actually I'm
serious I don't think he's doing
podcasts like this with everything going
we gotta get him on no no because reach
out because yeah go ahead and reach out
to Hunter Biden Brad let me know how it
goes for you I don't think he's doing
firing the kid dude he might know us
we're too much you might but we're too
much of wild card yeah and what we're
talking politics of him I don't give a
[__] about shitty politics no let's talk
to him about what it's like to be him
hey what's it like doing crack [__]
that's a great act that's a great he's
not answering that question yeah no he
he's like well I was back in the day no
no I'm talking like in the video laptop
that's on your laptop hey can we can we
bring up some of these hookers what'd
you do with that dude he's not doing
that stuff only only off air we've had
celebrities here who act super straight
laced and then we get never have them on
again and then we get them all no I'm
not here for that yeah I don't want to
do it on camera here like oh you're a
different person very rare because I
can't have them back no keep that same
energy on the mic what are you doing
dude Keith that same energy what are you
doing are you playing character on the
Pod it's a podcast yeah are you gonna
lose your career sure
sure
yo can't do fake that's why we stopped
booking actors yeah
correct all right Tim what do you got
do you guys do anything for the fourth
I saw a comedy show at the Hollywood
improv it was all right
it could have been packed on a July 4th
half full apparently the other room was
full of Rowdy teenagers all the
comedians were like teenagers they're
like we're getting heckled in there yeah
because teenagers don't know how to act
yeah one of the Asian comedians got
called Matt Rice instead of Matt Rife
that's hilarious that's pretty funny I
went to the beach and watched
professional volleyball players mix it
up men and women gay yeah and all I
wanted to be was a professional
volleyball player rock hard all the time
do you see any fireworks was I looking
at the guys more than the girls 100 any
fireworks no fireworks canceled why
particulates in the air
what the [__] that mean no fireworks
in the South Bay there's so many
fireworks out here really oh my you
sound like [__] world war dogs
because the neighborhood kids were
setting them off my poor dogs were
freaking out also but come on dog figure
it out right it's so annoying
it's once a year you [__] hounds I
know but God damn it welcome to America
I had to sit with my what's the Shippy
to China [__] where we got these
fireworks and get eaten alive
God you got a good thing going you're
you're you're you're speaking reason but
they don't know I know they're so
annoying once a year they freaked the
[__] out drooling out how to deal with
it wouldn't leave my feet oh God they're
so annoying figure it out man my German
Shepherd was fine she was like whatever
she's but she's been doing freaking out
yeah she's she's a working dog she's a
worker did you do anything last night
Jen did you see any fireworks yeah I'm
surprised because this is like this area
I thought there's gonna be zero fire or
not zero but very every year it's
popping like yeah outside my balcony is
just going crazy till like midnight yeah
I told my kids because they sleep
together Hey listen you hear like sounds
like gunshots it's not it's just the
fireworks and they were cool I heard
sirens going off but I doubt anyone got
arrested I heard sirens yeah plenty of
sirens fireworks are so illegal I sound
like we could have done that box that I
have is it still here we did have it in
the cool room there I still have it
that'd be fun give me uh too late now
give me some current events all right
bro here we go first one is the Ben and
Jerry's controversy this is on Fourth of
July too this is great so Ben and Jerry
on their Twitter and their website uh
they made this claim that us exists on
Stolen indigenous land do you guys hate
sales oh they're screwed now so this is
what they wrote exactly it's time to be
recognized the US exists on Stolen
indigenous land and commit to returning
it learn more and take action now and
this comes from two white guys Ben and
Jerry who use who utilized our system to
make a business and thrive in it now
they get to the top now whatever they
have white guilt they're trying to do
their thing they're screwed too give
this dude right here money back to who
yeah it looks like a walrus
so it says he's not he's not a stranger
to uh activism he donated one more than
a million dollars to a group to help
and the U.S military support of Ukraine
and if you go on their website I went on
the website they have this activism Tab
and it's literally just everything you
could possibly imagine
hey but also just make my [__] Cherry
Garcia ice cream and shut your [__]
mouth how about that also your ice cream
ain't [__] compared to the new ice cream
out now we love making it compared to
Afters compared to [__] Jenny's salt
and straw Ben and Jerry's can suck my
Native American [__] dude how about that
now here's what sucks my favorite shoes
are the Ben and Jerry dunks I can't wear
them right now ain't that a [__] hold
on go back when Kanye did his weird
Jewish thing
all right capitalism and the wealth of
producers did not do not create
opportunity for everyone equally we
recognize the gap between the rich and
the poorest wider than any time since
the 1920s we strive to create an
economic economic opportunities for
those who have been denied them into
advanced new models of economic Justice
that are sustainable [__] let's not push
them [__] these guys
two rich white guys you guys made money
off of capitalism yeah exactly the
entire business amazing and they're
based out of uh you think Portland but
no they're based out of somewhere on the
East Coast
literally everything
they just make ice cream
hey just make my [__] ice cream also
[__] Ben and Jerry's ain't [__]
well I thought this was interesting the
CEO of uh AI chatbot who makes chat GPT
he said in an interview that he says
you can imagine the best case scenario
being amazing first amazing scenario for
us but then the worst case would be
lights out for all of us with AI Texas
thoughts on the worst case scenario
though were pretty bleak the bad case I
think this is important to say it's like
lights out for all of us I'm not I'm
more worried about an accidental uh
misuse case in the short term yeah so I
think it's like impossible to overstate
the importance of AI safety and
Alignment work oh boy I would like to
see much much more happening yeah dude
it's like pros cons pros it cures all
cancer it could be amazing cons we could
all terminate them too yeah cons
Terminator two robots that just kill us
all and they just built one that looks
like the Terminator too
yeah it's just it's so sweet yeah so I
thought of Brendan because of this dude
and I [__] their names up never needs
her and all that that was so funny that
oh my my nephews because they're soccer
players just passing it went viral
people went viral on Tick Tock and on
like easy idiots and on uh some some
songs
oh my God but so Neymar at his Mansion
he built a a pond basically a lake and
apparently
the environmental authorities there are
finding them 3.5 million dollars
because they still keep the lake he
could yeah but he he gets fine 3.5 mil
every year he said something about a
transferring Fresh Water Resources sand
and rocks how big is the lake okay I
think this is the one to call it a lake
is pretty [__] let me know oh like a
mini Lake like this I think that's what
it is and does he have fish in there
I think he just swims in it to be honest
if this if this is the correct why is it
like it's just a big pool for God's
sakes yeah it's got Stones next to his
mansion that's lit dude that yeah makes
all the money but yeah 3.5 mil to do
that guys don't they have bigger
concerns in Brazil I don't know I'm just
spitballing ideas here yeah yeah and
that's his dad arguing with the
environmental activity that's like it's
a [__] pool you guys keep going on a
lake
yeah okay it'd be cool if you have like
an alligator they're like you know it's
like is this what you're worried about
I'm a guy made a little pool there and
then Neymar is bringing so much money
too oh my God
all right uh this is a quick MMA one
this came out of nowhere really Alistair
over him apparently he just retired he
said it in June which no one really
picked up on
and then he you remember we saw the
picture of him on shop show I lost all
that weight right here on the right good
for him apparently he met this guy
that's teaching about health and he
became a vegetarian so he only eats very
steroids I mean that's the biggest thing
weight loss thing tighten up your diet
that's what happens I call him
ozempicream
I think he looks healthy I'm proud of
him because you carry all that weight
when you get older like your heart the
blood pressure like he wants to live
long man everyone's like oh you're so
skinny yeah that's dope dude all that
weight I'm carrying all that weight
going that vegetarian like I don't know
he said something about
um it feels good when you eat meat
there's parasites that build up in your
body and you start craving more meat a
thousand times now that guy just got in
his ear I think he'll get over it but at
least he lost all the weight however you
got to get there to get all that weight
off he did it and I can eat some meat
dude as long as he's healthy then yeah
all that horse meat you see what are we
doing dude
yeah
I thought this was this thing's nuts
yeah 2.2 billion dollars what I don't
know how much that cost 2.2 billion
dollars this sphere they built
nuts it looks super cool
that's pretty badass Isn't that cool yes
have you seen the silver like Chrome one
they did on it oh God
but just the illusion looks awesome
here's my thing though what's it do it
just looks cool you know what it is it's
a part of the skyline that will never
change and when you think about Vegas
now Generations will think of that first
yeah I know hey 2.2 billion dollars
though I don't know hey let me ask you
bring it up Jim why would I make that up
be 2.2 2. billion yeah that look how big
it is dude you mean the whole structure
that thing cost 2.2 billion dollars
think of all the technology Brian and
it's waterproof waterproof 2.3 oh I'm
sorry I was off my back 2.3 you [__] I
don't think it costs that much I don't
know what the [__] I'm talking about
right well the whole story let's do that
again look at the whole structure yeah
dude that thing costs 2.3 billion
dollars oh to build the whole thing and
that's a building oh you thought I was
talking about a part of it I thought it
was just a globe
how crazy is that 2.3 billion dollars
that's the structure holy [__] here's my
thing makes sense why though right yeah
like school for it to look once it's
pretty cool I I just don't know what you
do with it is it like is it a hotel
inside it's an architectural Wonder
no I don't wonder I know they did it and
they'll see their money back
yeah over time for sure but is it Hotel
what's in there
um it's probably a place where what
would you say young Jacks will go right
so it's like did you play the oh there
it is it's the sphere what's that
Venetian yeah it'll be here
Resort he sold out the sphere it'll be
that you know
yeah they have restaurants yeah so it's
gonna be a hotel they might have it says
entertainment too so maybe fights in
there that's crazy
it's nuts looking right
it looks super cool
I saw this one on Instagram was silver
it's like a chrome
insane I don't like it when they do the
big Fireball go to Olivia Dunn yeah so
it's taking the money uh she's super hot
obviously she's a highest paid and then
so they she did an interview and
apparently they asked her like what's
what's the you know how much money take
off the post and then she said they said
over 500 or under 500 she was over 500
000 for a single post 500 500 you see
your Sports Illustrated shoe no no but I
see her Instagram and she's freaking hot
how old is she before we get in trouble
she's like 23 years old yeah repair game
she's so gorgeous yeah
she's smoking I mean are you [__]
kidding me
and she's a sick athlete
well yeah
her uh her um
Jesus Christ but her uh
why is she cool
looks weird there but go up Jen because
her Sports Illustrated is the one where
she's on the beach keep going
right there yeah that one that's on
Sports Illustrated
huh crazy what's your thing
if that's your thing I guess
who she date
I name somebody yeah yeah who wouldn't
sign up for that
let's just see real quick I don't think
she's dealing with she
makes so much more money
with who the [__] is Josh
there's some friends I'm Chad bro that's
all it is
wow
well
Josh Richards baseball pitcher
just doing the damn thing in Triple A or
some [__]
oh no so Theo Milos is a pitcher I don't
know man I'm sure she has plenty plenty
of boyfriends
yeah but yeah she's hot yeah I'm sure
there's yeah I'm sure her DMS are look
at her flooded I mean look at her
yeah what are you talking about
I mean she's so famous though
as a gymnast yeah gymnast is she even on
the Olympic team
I don't think she's at that level I
don't think yeah and she's in college
just a run-of-the-mill chick I think
as far as gym gymnastic goes I don't
know gymnastics I think she's actually
uh was really good oh she was on the
national team that's a big deal that's
really hard she's the highest valued
women's college athlete out for the nil
I heard you for an hour the name image
likeness I think the only one above her
is being on the U.S national team is
LeBron's son Ronnie that's the only
person I think she's higher than him I
just read something really if she's
getting five thousand five hundred
thousand posts because I know LeBron's
son well maybe was just one deal he
signed for 2.2 and he was in high school
that's what I'm saying what huh but good
on them
was really bizarre this is on American
Airlines I'll just show you the clip
here on Tick Tock it's a woman saying
that she doesn't
think someone's real I'll show you real
quick and you know who's on this flight
care Top Care top is on this flight I
don't know this [__] was crazy I feel
bad for these people too too much acid
it must be a must be like some sort of
drugs I haven't seen this
I'm telling you she looks normal too and
there's a reason why
[Music]
someone leave it
it's not bad looking no
[Music]
I'm not going to just get off the plane
and it held up to everyone for three
hours three hours three hours why why so
long just like man come with us it's
obvious she's crazy yeah or something's
wrong or or this is the plot from Final
Destination and she's spot on and the
guy's just like lizard he's like why'd
you do this
I wonder what she was on though I would
have done that to her I would have been
like hired do you think I'm real yeah or
what if it was the guy who just had like
botox he's like God damn it that's
embarrassing and he's not real or she's
talking about Carrot Top he's not real
now look at his face he's all hey hey be
cool be cool so I'm getting off the
planes like you piece of [__] that's
interesting dear impaled on oh that's
for uh Stephen King but I'll show you
this real quick another attack happened
where a woman was walking her dog and
this is in South Carolina and she's like
what happened apparently killed by an
alligator it's always old ladies
strolling by 69 so that's not crazy it
was like a 15-foot Gator and they said
the gator wouldn't let the people try to
like they wanted to recover the body we
kept like watching the body yeah
and what it was a big old body right big
old uh Gator
dinosaur dinosaur I don't know the
length of the gator
I could there be anything worse than
getting killed by Gator Man
yeah at least they're old I bet it
happens fast and there was like walking
dogs it seems like it's when they're
walking they're always by the [__]
wall yeah she was by the actual Shore is
there any warnings that there's Gators
there though there's got to be now yeah
anytime you're in Florida there are
gators everywhere and this is South
Carolina this South Carolina same thing
I'm going there I'll be there I'll be in
South Carolina Friday Saturday this
Friday Saturday Greenville I'm glad I
knew I didn't know that by the way so
I'm glad you told me that now now that
I'm reminded of that South Carolina you
don't Gators are diamonds but I don't
think of South Carolina as gay and it's
like Florida I don't I wouldn't go on a
kitty pool but South Carolina probably
would have done it now I know yeah
deer impaled on spiders this is Stephen
King's house on a fence a junior
suddenly got impaled right there oh he
tried jumping through it yeah probably
went through his tummy now that's good
eating because if nobody's looking I'm
taking that deer and I'm skinning it
also side note Stephen King's house
haunted as [__] look at that thing it
looks scary for sure I mean he's a scary
writer right yeah he even looks scary
well he went through a lot of drug and
alcohol he doesn't remember writing
anything that's right he was too drunk
he's I don't remember said I don't
remember writing Cujo
didn't he get hit by a car too yep got
really [__] up go to the misery a
ghost car that was a ghost car
they finally paid him back clowns and
they got out and they threw pies in
there and they were ghosts
in his face actually yeah
he was covering dude that dude wrote
Shawshank Redemption he wrote it the
guard is the best movie of all the
shining I mean he's a misery he's one of
the greatest he is the Great American
writer pet cemetery
the stand
he's just an incredible writer
down in the wind how about it gone in
the wind they didn't write that okay
gone with the one
no see you're thinking You're Gone With
the Wind he wrote gone what am I in the
win God in the way got to win yeah it
wasn't moving
by farce it didn't do well
oh yeah
yeah he looks crazy yeah all right kids
all right is that it that should be it
that should be it on Stephen King we did
it I get a bunch of tour dates coming up
be announced for August gotta the August
is packed it's coming up kids don't
worry shopping friends of Pasadena July
28th I have some monsters on that show
one show only at 8pm Spokane comedy club
one of my faves September 21st the 23rd
and your boys at skank Fest it's going
down skank Fest Vegas I was saying that
I'm gonna stay in that weird uh we both
are I don't know if you'll be you want
to stay in your room you wanna stay in
that sphere with me
hopefully it's open let's share a bed
and stop pretending all right guys I'm
gonna be in uh I'll be at the uh Comedy
Zone in Greenville South Carolina uh
July 7th and 8th this Friday Saturday
and you know what Brian's going to do
Brian's going to kill alligators for you
guys yeah I'm right then I'll be at the
Blue Room July 21-22
I can't wait all right kids love you